good afternoon everyone please remain
standing for a moment is University
chaplain Jenelle Davis leads us in the
invocation first I'm glad to see you
when it's not raining thanks to all of
you who did go downtown congratulations
new physicians congratulations new PhDs
you have reached for your dreams you
have worked hard to achieve goals to
become healthcare researchers and
practitioners you have sacrificed you
have met challenges you have faced
obstacles you have been sleep-deprived
yet you have stayed a course that
required personal stamina consistent
determination and remarkable moral
courage we give thanks for the quality
of care and for the honest hope that you
will provide to those who will rely on
your skills seek your good counsel count
on the soundness of your judgement and
trust your professional integrity
respect the dignity of your patients be
humbled by the respect and high esteem
that your patients and their families
will assign to you be wise and humane be
just and generous be compassionate
preserve your good spirit hold as sacred
lifelong learning and protect your open
heart may it be so may it be so
excuse me sue
it's really my privilege to welcome the
MD and PhD graduates of the class of two
k10 to today's ceremonies and also want
to thank all the family and friends who
are here what I'd like you to do is to
have all the students stand up turn
around find someone here who helped you
get here and thank them by clapping for
them
thank you to everyone's family and
friends for being here today and for
sharing this very special time as you
heard from chaplain Davis I also want to
hope that everyone is dried out from
this morning's event you will be I think
pleased to hear that until about two
years ago this event was also outside
and fortunately moved inside this is a
track and field venue I like to think of
this as exemplifying the fact that a
career in medicine is not a sprint it's
a very nice marathon and today is really
the beginning of that and as part of
that I usually use this time to give my
brief remarks sort of the history of
medicine as applied to where you are now
in your career but first you may not be
surprised at president Bollinger who
could not deliver his address downtown
ask me to read it in its entirety
I said no see I get my rather brief
address I like to use this as a time to
talk about what I'll call the bridged
version of the history of Medicine
downtown the students with me recite the
Hippocratic oath we'll do it again here
and if you ask someone what's an
Hippocratic oath they usually don't know
but they remember sort of vaguely this
one basic concept which is do no harm
and in many ways medicine began with
that fundamental principle do no harm
what's amazing is for how long medicine
mostly did harm and it wasn't
intentional it wasn't because doctors
didn't mean well it was not because they
didn't care or try to care it was
because they just didn't know any better
and it's sort of hard to believe that a
profession whose abiding principle was
do no harm
relied on such treatments
as bloodletting purging leeches actually
leeches have come back a little bit but
those sorts of treatments aren't just
hard to believe there's still debate
about whether George Washington really
died from his pharyngeal infection and
because they took so much blood from
them so for much of our history that's
what doctors did in my career I've been
a proponent of what's called
hospitalists students know what I mean
the medical students because hospitals
are now doctors who help take care of
sick patients while they're in the
hospital and they had a special training
special role in doing so when we first
started this career pathway of
hospitalists people called the field
hospital ISM kind of made sense and then
someone wrote me a note saying do you
really know what hospital is Amin's
turns out that the term hospitalist
is new the term hospital ism has been
around for centuries it referred to all
the bad things that happened when he
went to a hospital and it's hard to
remember but for much of humankind
hospitals the extent to which they
existed were alms houses for people who
were too poor to be cared at home it was
that the hospitals had anything special
to offer it's just as if you're too poor
to be cared for in the relative safety
an isolation of your home where you
could only get infections from those who
happen to be in your home you'd go to a
hospital or you catch things from lots
of other people and so hospital ism
really meant all the bad things that
happen in hospitals medicine really
began to change in Germany in the mid to
late nineteenth century with the
movement called in the German I'm not
very good at German so you'll forgive me
in nuran in medicine loosely translated
now into internal medicine and that's
not to say the internal medicine is the
only specialty that focuses on
scientific medicine which is really what
in ER in medicine
meant it's that that was when medicine
began fundamentally to change for a
profession that tried to see what
someone was complaining about and give
them something that would treat that to
have professional try to understand the
fundamental underlying causes of disease
after World War two in the United States
we see the rise of health insurance for
hospitalization now hospitals actually
can do things that can be beneficial and
during the wage and price freezes of the
post-world War two ERA providing fringe
benefits was a way to compete for
skilled workers and what the major
fringe benefits was health insurance
which would provide for coverage when
people went to the hospital because now
even people would be afford to be cared
for at home would go to the hospital for
things that couldn't be done at home
after World War two we also see the rise
of the NIH and fundamental biomedicine
being supported here in this country we
see epidemiology coming of age was the
framing framing framing hinge heart
study which identified the causes of
heart disease including something we'll
talk more about later which is
cholesterol and ultimately randomized
trials bring evidence and create
evidence-based medicine and to give you
a sense of how important that is I think
back to when I was early in my training
and just about to be look long to the
faculty for the first time and there's a
proposal to do a randomized trial of the
medications that suppress irregular
heartbeats arrhythmias which some of you
learn how to spell yesterday and since
we knew that arrhythmias were associated
with death and we knew these medications
suppress the arrhythmias it was
obviously logical that the medications
that suppress the arrhythmias would
prevent death and these medications were
used widely one might even say
indiscriminately when the concept came
to a randomized trial to
prove this logical progression many
doctors thought it was patently
unethical how could you possibly have
patients in a control group how could
you possibly test something that was so
logical seemed to be so true well
ultimately the study was done not
surprisingly was stopped before the
projected number enrollees because one
group did far better than the other
what's amazing was as a group that did
better was a group that got lucy-belle
the group that received the medication
it seemed effectively to suppress the
arrhythmias was more likely to die the
logical progression of thought was not
truly evidence you're going to be
entering the medical profession as
practitioners as researchers as PhD
scientists an era when we really care
about the evidence when we really care
about knowing what's right and we
believe that medicine is this
combination of caring which has existed
for many centuries and real science
which is a relatively new development
that allows that caring to be expressed
in ways that are far more beneficial to
the patient's who count us for their
care it's this wonderful profession that
you'll become a member and this
profession and your accomplishments do
we celebrate today before I go to the
faculty Awards I'd like to thank the
faculty and administrative staff are
here in the stage with me for their
leadership throughout the year and for
their role in your education I also want
to explicitly acknowledge one of our
Columbia University Trustees dr. Kenneth
Ford who's going to assist me with a
presentation of the faculty Awards dr.
Ford dr. Ford is a chair of the Health
Sciences trustees the University
subcommittee responsible for trying to
keep me in line
yesterday's you know we had the student
Awards today as the time for the faculty
award the Distinguished Service Award so
the highest awards we give and recognize
individuals who have served the College
of Physicians and Surgeons with the
greatest distinction bringing honor to
the institution to its alumni into the
profession itself today's honorees are
Katherine claim and Andrew France
Katherine dr. Colleen professor emeritus
microbiology and biochemistry and
molecular biophysics has had a
distinguished career in which she's made
major contributions in multiple areas of
molecular immunology her work has shed
light on gene regulation and lymphocyte
development and the immune system
she's an elected member of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences of the
Institute of Medicine she serves an
advisory boards for the NIH and for the
Howard Hughes Medical Institute she's an
excellent teacher who was instrumental
in organizing the school's main
immunology course I also want
acknowledge dr. France who's unable to
be with us today dr. France is a
professor of medicine associate dean for
admissions at pns and he's the person
who had the good judgment to admit all
of you to the Medical School he served
as our Dean of admission since 1981
but before that even during some of his
time is Dean of Admissions his
laboratory was the first to show that
human prolactin exists in human
pituitary's and circulates in the blood
as a hormone distinct from human growth
hormone later his laboratory was the
first to develop the bioassay by which
prolactin could be measured in serum as
normal physiology and abnormal
physiology and pituitary tumors for
example could be explored
dr. claim and dr. France who can't be
with us here today
please accept our appreciation of these
awards for distinguished service to the
College of Physicians and Surgeons
next to that Charles W Baum Folk Awards
established for the generosity of John
Frederick and house Baum flock the
member of a graduate of the p NS class
of 1884 not 1984 1884 these awards
recognize distinguished teaching in the
preclinical and clinical years this
year's Baum Falk award for preclinical
teaching goes to dr. Jonathan brash
Jonathan
Johnathan's associate professor of
medicine and anatomy and cell biology he
completed his MD PhD and residences here
should get you a car as he teaches
students in all four years has
consistently received fantastic reviews
for his skills just a sample of comments
from one student I really appreciate the
opportunity to learn how to start
approaching problem-solving from the
perspective of such a brilliant doctor
another simply said dr. brash equals
greatest person ever this year is asked
to lead the transformation of the basic
science portion of the entire first
semester of the first year which
resulted in new integrated course called
molecular mechanisms his emphasis that
students learn to formulate questions
and hypotheses and discuss original
literature to show the students how
scientists come to conclusions and how
facts are defined it's a pleasure to
award dr. brash with the bomb Faulk
Award for distinguished teaching
the bomb clock award for clinical
teaching is award to dr. Katherine
Nickerson dr. Nickerson is a professor
of clinical medicine and currently
directs the third year clerkship in
internal medicine she's a graduate of
the University of California San
Francisco has been here at pns since
1984 through her work on Columbia's
teaching partnership with Basset
Healthcare in upstate New York she's
been instrumental in helping us launch a
new model of medical training designed
to address the nation's severe shortage
of rural physicians she also receives
just spectacular reviews for her
teaching skills quote such as dr.
Nickerson consistently runs the most
viable hours of my week and she's able
to teach the skill level that was
appropriate for medical students and for
residents in fact in 2001 dr. Nickerson
actually received the same award for the
preclinical year so you're not unlike
the double it's our pleasure to honor
dr. Nickerson with the Baum Falk Award
for distinguished teaching
the Leonard Tao humanism and medicine
award from the Arnold Gould foundation
is presented each year to a student and
also to a faculty physician who's
demonstrated compassionate and devoted
patient care and who was a humanistic
role model for students and young
physicians this year's awardee is dr.
Leslie Simpson the humanism award was
renamed in 2003 to honor Leonard Tao
person who's lived his life with great
compassion and respect for others
there's a real personal friend of mine
and of the University and whose name is
really associated with the integrity and
caring that serve as the core mission of
the Gould foundation dr. Simpson is an
associate professor of obstetrics and
gynecology chief of obstetrics and the
division of chief for maternal and fetal
medicine and medical director of this
Center for prenatal pediatrics she's an
outstanding clinician and ultrason
ologist who sees mothers with high-risk
pregnancies some of whom may develop
life-threatening situations with little
warning she delivers patient care with
compassion and sensitivity while
balancing professionalism humanism and
her medical practice she has the ability
to bring hope to uncertain stressful
situations while still being realistic
about the outcomes she's a dedicated
teacher and mentor as described by our
fellows as a brilliant clinician
dedicated advocate and beloved selfless
teacher dr. Simpson for exemplified the
standards of the Leonard Tao humanism in
medicine award it's our pleasure to
recognize you here today
the herald and golden Lamport research
awards were initiated in 1983 to honor
outstanding young researchers and the
basic and clinical sciences this year's
dr. Howell Dan Goldin Lamport research
award and basic sciences goes to dr.
Fiona Deutsch
dr. Deutsch was recruited to pns in 2003
as an assistant professor in pathology
and cell biology neuroscience and
neurology is part of our stem cell
initiative her interdepartmental
research uses a variety of molecular
cellular and genetic approaches to
discover the regulation lineage
relationships diversity and function of
stem cells and neuronal production in
the adult mammalian brain her study of
the biology of neural stem cells and
their in vivo niche is key to
understanding brain repair and neural
pathologies including tumors and also
certain lead to other insights in stem
cell fields dr. Deutsch is an honor to
present you was the dr. Harold and
golden Lamport research award in basic
science congratulations
the doctor howl Dan Goldin Lamport
research award in clinical sciences this
year goes dr. Anthony Ferrante dr.
Ferrante is the Dorothy and Daniel
Silverberg assistant professor of
medicine and he studies the molecular
mechanisms of insulin resistance and the
effects of obesity on the cardiovascular
system his research in our not only
buried Diabetes Center has shown that
large increases in fat mass lead to
obesity adversely altered blood pressure
insulin sensitivity serum lipid profiles
and cardiac functions his interest in
the metabolic aspects of inflammation
have led to findings who represent the
very best in translational research
improving our understanding of molecular
biology and both human and rodent
systems dr. Ferrante I'm delighted to
present you with the daryl dr. harold
and golden Lamport research award in
clinical sciences
the class of 2010 selects the
distinguished teacher award
now you heard his stirring presentation
yesterday and certainly got a sense for
why he's the winner of this award by our
tradition this award will be presented
by this year's class president John
Kasper good afternoon everyone
it's truly an honor to present this
award to a professor who gave us some of
the most outstanding lectures in our
first year in cardiovascular medicine
and pulmonary medicine and more
importantly took an interest in us not
just as students or budding
professionals but as people and he
haven't said everyday when you walked by
him or if you see him in the hospital he
says hi and he's really interested in
what you're doing and how you're doing
it's it's really been a privilege to be
an institution with people like this and
Mark Dickstein
dr. Dickstein you were a tremendous
professor and the class of 2010 is
honored to give you this award
it's now my pleasure to introduce
today's speaker the Nobel laureate dr.
Michael Brown over the years dr. Brown
who shared the 1985 Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine with his close
friend Joseph Goldstein has spoken
widely about the essential attributes of
clinical research and the challenges of
drug discovery his story though is
really I think remarkable while in
training he and dr. Goldstein were asked
to see the two siblings ages six and
eight years old who were dying of
recurrent heart attacks the cause was
genetically elevated level of the
cholesterol carrying low-density
lipoprotein LDL the so called bad
cholesterol the children were born with
cholesterol levels over a thousand and
started having heart attacks before the
age of five
they had a rare genetic abnormality
called homozygous familial
hypercholesterolemia which affects about
one in a million children and they were
determined to find the cause of this
defect not only because of the rare
child with this homozygous affliction
but also because the parents of these
children who are heterozygous also had
substantially elevated cholesterol
levels that put them for great risk of
heart attacks not at age six or eight
but prematurely during adulthood and
together in a remarkable example of the
kind of teamwork that I will argue is
now the way all of medicine is practiced
they discovered the LDL receptor in the
liver that controls the level of
cholesterol in the blood and in the
cells the students know the story well
but for the rest of you think of this
sort of as a thermostat that's supposed
to sense the temperature in this case
the
the ll but doesn't and goes haywire and
keeps on telling the liver to turn up
the heat in this case the cholesterol
level their work led to the cloning of
the receptor the understanding of how it
worked and formed the fundamental basis
for the statins the drug that most of
you familiar with which basically fools
the receptor into thinking there's yet
even more cholesterol so even a
defective thermostat will turn down the
heat
statins today are taken by more than
twenty million people worldwide and we
can argue that probably even more should
be taking them a dr. Brown's research
has continued at the molecular cellular
and whole-body level to study various
other mechanisms underlying cholesterol
metabolism dr. Brown was born right here
in Brooklyn later moved to Elkins Park
Pennsylvania was educated the University
of Pennsylvania for versus both his BA
and MD degrees did his training at the
Massachusetts General Hospital and moved
in 1971 to Dallas Texas at that time an
outpost but with his leadership and
leadership of others became one of the
extraordinary medical medical research
complexes in the US he's of course a
member of all the right societies
including the National Academy of
Sciences the Institute of Medicine and
the Royal Society of London he with dr.
Goldstein won the Gairdner award the
Horowitz Award the Lasker prize the u.s.
National Medal of Science and the Nobel
Prize we hard to find someone who better
exemplifies a strong understanding of
clinical medicine trained as a real
doctor attended an awards but also
understands science and the translation
of that science to improving humankind
it's really my pleasure to introduce a
friend a colleague and a role model for
all of us dr. Michael Brown
Thank You dr. Goldman for that really
over-the-top introduction I don't
deserve it frankly but I'm honored to be
asked to give this address today and
Dean Goldman future physicians of the
class of 2010 proud parents relatives
friends of the graduates members of the
faculty and all other voyeurs of this
joyous occasion congratulations to the
class of 2010
let me tell you that your that your
faculty and administration really cares
about you when I agreed to give this
lecture I received at least five or six
letters and emails urging me to keep my
remarks brief less than ten minutes so
they do care I promise that my speech
will not be the longest in commencement
history which was given at Harvard 200
years ago it lasted six hours the first
three in Latin and the last three in
Greek but my speech will also not be the
shortest which was given by your
distinguished fellow New Yorker Woody
Allen who gave his advice in just three
words don't screw up my topic today will
be class CLA SS Columbia graduates have
class all great physicians have class
what do I mean by class class has five
letters these letters stand for the five
attributes that make a great doctor for
the rest of this lecture I'll discuss
these attributes one by one
C stands for compassion this is the
first requirement by compassion I don't
mean ordinary compassion simply feeling
sorry for people
I mean medical compassion which is much
more challenging and demanding medical
compassion is what you feel when you
tell a young man that he has an
inoperable brain tumor or worse when you
tell a young couple that their child
must undergo painful operations that may
not even work such bad news must be
conveyed by the physician in charge it
can't be left to nurses or social
workers or office assistants
it can't be done by fax or email or even
the telephone you have to look the
patients in the eye and convince them
that you will do everything possible to
help they must feel your compassion and
it must be real medical compassion is
what you need when you're a house
officer and you curl up for a few
minutes of sleep on a cot in the
emergency room at 3 a.m. and you're
awakened 15 minutes later because
there's a homeless man in the emergency
room who is vomiting blood he's filthy
smelly unshaven and intoxicated and he
doesn't want to be there he struggles
and curses you and everyone else and
you've got to impose yourself on this
man and make him better even though he
doesn't want to be better medical
compassion is not inborn it must be
learned and I'll tell you when you learn
it you learn it the next morning when
the nurses and orderlies have cleaned up
the patient have wiped away his vomit
and his blood have bathed him and shaved
him and the intoxication is gone and you
find out that he is really a human being
a person and that's when you're thankful
for medical compassion it gets you over
the rough spots Metro compassion is
essential now because it sometimes
conflicts with HMOs and their
cost-benefit analysis which says that
it's cheaper to let a few people die of
breast cancer than it is to pay for
routine screening mammograms it's
cheaper to let a few die of heart
attacks rather than to pay for
cholesterol-lowering medicines this is
the same logic that the Ford Motor
Company used when it calculated that it
was cheaper to settle the occasional
lawsuit
obviously I've offended the Ford Motor
Company
then your thang you know the Ford Motor
Company used the same logic when they
calculated that it was cheaper to the
settle the occasional lawsuit rather
than to fixed the equipment the
exploding gas tank on the Ford Pinto as
a physical as a physician I cannot
accept this logic it conflicts with my
compassion for the individual compassion
creates tension between physicians and
HMOs please don't lose your compassion
even when the HMO disagrees I've spent a
lot of time on compassion because it's
the most essential attribute of the
physician compassion is your American
Express card don't leave home without it
compassion is essential but it's not
sufficient without the other four
attributes compassion would be futile
what do the other four letters of clasp
stand for L stands for learning to be a
physician you must know how the body
functions when it is healthy and what
goes wrong when it's diseased at
Columbia you've started to acquire this
knowledge it began with gross anatomy
you pried into a human being with an
intimacy that society allows only for
physicians you examined every muscle
artery vein nerve and bone you teased
apart the kidneys the heart and the
brain you studied the cells that make up
these organs and you learned the
biochemistry that powers the cells and
you learned how genes orchestrate the
whole process you learned how the body
fights back when it's attacked from the
outside
and how it decays when age hardens the
inside and you learned how physicians
use drugs to forestall death many of you
complained about all of this learning
the amount of knowledge is too great how
can any one person know more than a
small piece of it although your
generation has more to learn than my
generation you have one advantage that
my generation lacked the computer the
world's greatest library in your bedroom
this difference between generations
reminds me of a story twenty-two years
ago Joe Goldstein and I received the
National Medal of Science from President
Ronald Reagan at the White House
President Reagan told a story about the
time he was governor of California in
1967 and an angry delegation of college
students barged into his office they
were typical students of the 60s long
hear
beards t-shirts cut off pants sandals
they challenged his decisions about the
University of California and their
leader cried out how can you possibly
govern us our world is different than
yours when you grew up you didn't have
jet planes television computers
high-speed communications you can't
possibly understand us
well mr. Reagan thought for a while and
then he said you know you're right my
generation was not born with jet planes
television computers or high-speed
communications we invented them well
just as the students of the 60s faces a
new world so do you face a new world of
Medicine my century the 20th century was
the extrinsic century when the century
began the major killers were extrinsic
invaders that cause pneumonia
tuberculosis syphilis diphtheria cholera
scarlet fever we conquered them all your
century the 21st century will be the
intrinsic century
the major killers of your time are
intrinsic to the human body
heart disease cancer dementia and the
aging process itself my generation has
presented your generation with a new
weapon the human genome sequence used
properly this sequence will help you
conquer the intrinsic diseases whose
ultimate causes lie not in our stars but
in our genes in the 20th century
medicine was one-size-fits-all in the
21st century medicine will be custom
fitted to each person's genome as
physicians you must be ready for this
revolution to be ready you must continue
to learn Columbia has given you a head
start but you must maintain the momentum
on your own keep learning let's return
to class to be a physician with class
you need compassion and learning what
does the a stand for a stands for a
students which is wisdom or judgment
you can you can be full of compassion
and learning but without a students you
won't know when to apply that learning
you can't learn a students from a
computer it comes only from observations
during your residency pick out the
smartest person you can find it might be
a fellow resident or it might be a
senior physician figure out why they're
so smart how do they always know the
right thing to do test yourself by
trying to anticipate their decisions why
did they decide that this woman should
have a radical mastectomy and another
woman a lumpectomy there is no right or
wrong answer you can't make medical
decisions based only on statistics
remember doctors treat individual human
beings a decision that is right for one
patient may be wrong for another this is
a students and you learn it by
imitation class has two S's the first S
stands for skill
compassion learning and astuteness are
useless without skills you've already
begun to learn those skills you started
by learning how to take a history and do
a physical examination you learned how
to size up a patient with all of your
sense organs your eyes your nose your
hands and the physicians most important
organ your ears you learned the three
special skills of the medical student
finding holding and inventing finding a
missing chart a missing x-ray a missing
lab report or a fresh pizza at three am
holding a retractor steady for hours
without falling into the incision and
inventing an answer on rounds and doing
it so convincingly that the professor
thinks you must be right as residents
you will learn new skills learn them
well you must aim to be the best at
everything you do whether it's by
passing an artery
catching a baby or pushing a colonoscope
you have to gain confidence in your
skills so that you don't fear
challenging tasks in your heart of
hearts you must believe that you are
better than anyone else at what you do
now we come to the final s the last of
the five attributes and the one that
differentiates the physician from all
other healers the first four attributes
are not unique to medicine compassion
learning astuteness and skill social
workers have those attributes so do
ministers rabbis and priests I even knew
a compassionate lawyer once they heal in
their own way what makes a physician
different the answer is the final s and
it stands for science I'm not talking
about laboratory science I'm talking
about the philosophy of science
very much that what Dean Goldman was
saying a few minutes ago the core
beliefs that date back to Hippocrates we
have four fundamental beliefs one we
believe that all diseases are produced
by physical or chemical mechanisms that
obey the laws of nature two we believe
that we can learn these mechanisms if
we're smart enough three we believe that
mechanism based treatments can prevent
or cure disease and four we choose these
treatments based on scientific evidence
the belief in rational mechanisms and
them and the demand for evidence to
justify treatment are the two features
that distinguish physicians from all
other healers to quote my great teacher
in Dallas Donald Selden physicians are
people who applied medical science to
the relief of pain and suffering in
individual human beings no other element
of society can do this it is our unique
role and our sacred obligation our
science is not perfect often we must
take actions that aren't fully justified
by scientific evidence and sometimes we
must change our tactics as new science
overthrows old dogmas this constant
updating is part of the scientific
process itself in science all ideas are
open to challenge at Columbia your
education has been based in science you
are primed to practice in an analytic
mode I urge you to keep practicing this
way for the rest of your life well there
you have it
CLA SS five letters that define a great
physician compassion tells you that you
must do something
learning tells you what to do
astute inist tells you when to do it
skill tells you how to do it and science
tells you why you're doing it
let me repeat those because it's really
important compassion
tells you that you must do something
learning tells you what to do
astute inist tells you when to do it
science tells you how to do it a skill
tells you how to do it and science tells
you why you're doing it
engrave these five letters in your mind
and remember them as you heal your
patients only then will you fulfill the
hopes that columbia has for each one of
you go forth and make us proud and don't
screw up
so just as the education of medical
students is bifurcated most of the first
two years science most of the second two
years clinical the PhD students first
year and a half or so in the classroom a
rest of the time in the laboratory so
too is our graduation bifurcated we are
now finished with everything serious and
now it's just about the fun I'm a thank
dr. Brown for being such an important
part of the seriousness and dr. Ford and
all of our Award winners
dr. Melman who's the senior associate
dean for Student Affairs gets to lead
the fun part oh stop sorry actually dr.
Robinson instantly the first part of the
fun part Richard Robinson who is our
vice dean for graduate students will
come up and join me to present the
diplomas to the graduate students and I
should begin by saying that since
graduate students graduated various
times during the year when they finished
the theses there were lots of graduate
students who aren't here today we're
delighted that so many of you were able
to join us both downtown and uptown rich
thank you congratulations to all of our
MD and PhD graduates we're going to
start with two dean awards for
excellence in research and then go on to
issuing of the diplomas we have over 350
students at the medical campus working
toward a PhD in biomedical science with
about 10% of them being combined MD PhDs
most of those students are engaged in
basic research but often progress in
that research requires technical and
methodological advances this year's two
recipients of the Dean's Award for
Excellence in research illustrate this
point both awardees developed new
methods during their doctoral studies
that are likely to create the impact
future research but more than that each
went on to apply those methods to
fundamental questions in their
respective fields generating important
new basic science insights I'd like to
invite the recipients up to the podium
now please they are Jesse Richardson
Jones from the graduate program
pharmacology and molecular signaling
whose mentor was dr. Renee hen and
sumeet serin from the graduate program
genetics and development whose mentor
was dr. Oliver Hobart
let me very briefly tell you about each
of their research Jessi defended her PhD
with distinction last summer Jessi's
thesis research encompasses two
exceptional conceptual advantages with
scientific field first providing a
causal mechanism to explain treatment
response and resistance in clinical
depression and second providing novel
roles for two populations of serotonin
1a receptors in the brain in addition to
these conceptual advances her work has
also brought an exciting technical
advance to the field of transgenic mouse
research in the form excuse me of a
novel system for gene suppression in the
mouse brain the novel findings jesse has
generated are doing large parts of the
elegant and specific manipulations she
is able to achieve with this genetic
system sumeet defended his PhD in
December his effort to position aliy
clone a gene using whole genome
sequencing methods and C elegans has
begun to revolutionize the landscape of
neurogenetics and invertebrate model
systems this work resulted in a pair of
papers in Nature Methods that are likely
to be heavily cited in the research
community using this methodology Sumeet
went on to clone three
neurodevelopmental mutants and in the
course of doing so provided an
intriguing example of multi genic trait
loci one that would have been almost
impossible to figure out by conventional
genetics Jessie and some eat it gives me
great pleasure to present you with these
awards
okay inclusion including the award
recipients we have 75 students who
earned their PhD in the past year as dr.
Goldman said they finish at various
times during the year unlike the medical
students who finish as a cohort and so
only some of them are able to return and
be with us today I would now ask
assistant dean loaf to come up and join
dr. goldman and i as we hand out the
diplomas
I ask all all candidates for the PhD
degree to please stand as I call your
name please step forward to receive your
degree Michael e bales biomedical
informatics
Sonia Tatiana bracel genetics and
development Jill s Carmody nutritional
and metabolic biology Katherine and
Fantauzzo genetics and development with
distinction dr. Fontes o is also the
recipient of the Samuel Rover and Lewis
Rover award for outstanding achievement
in genetics and development Yuri
Kochiyama nutritional and metabolic
biology Aliki Castelli nutritional and
metabolic biology Francis Joseph Martin
pharmacology and molecular signaling
with distinction Maggie
O'Meara genetics and development
christopher oliver ortiz neurobiology
and behavior it's not neo aaron paraguas
nutritional and metabolic biology with
distinction alyssa marie
puccini pharmacology and molecular
signaling with distinction Jesse W
Richardson Jones pharmacology and
molecular signaling with distinction
Sumeet sarin genetics and development
Hudson Davidson biomedical informatics
Sarah
Colleen Steen rod neurobiology and
behavior Chinchin
Katie Chu biomedical informatics
congratulations to all of our PhD
recipients it's actually a very special
treat for us to be able to have this
combined graduation ceremony for both
the MD students and also for the PhD
students who've done their PhDs with our
faculties in the medical school and now
where I thought I was before but I have
slight brain cramp dr. Lisa Melman are a
senior associate dean for student
affairs
it's a tremendous pleasure to welcome
you this is a class of inspired and
giving students who truly make a
difference they started a new clinic for
the homeless
they added a mental health arm to
another student-run free clinic they
initiated a firt the first of an annual
multicultural show they fund raised for
victims of the Haiti earthquake and they
ought us over and over with their
musical dance and athletic talent many
conducted research some got a second
degree they looked out for one another
and partnered with faculty and
administration to make our school and
community a better place we send you the
class of 2010 your families and your
significant others a hearty
congratulations
let me tell you let me tell you a little
bit more about the class with a hundred
and sixty six graduates this is the
biggest class in the history of pianist
we have 46 percent women making 54
percent men in terms of dual degrees 13
or MD PhDs five MD MPH Master of Public
Health 10 MD MBA Master of Business
Administration - MD DDS and an
additional 31 did an extra year of
research resulting in 37 percent who
took extra time for research or a dual
degree 24 percent matched at Columbia
for part or all of their postgraduate
training 44% will remain in New York
State for training mostly in New York
City this is a class that came to know
one another well in fact 12 couples
matched from this class 8 in which both
parties are in the class and 4 shared
with other schools 6 babies were born
during medical school and another is due
any moment
as Dean Goldman says medical school
indeed is a marathon and in fact 19
marathons actual marathons were run by
members of this class graduates in the
envelope that you received today in
addition to your diploma you'll find a
copy of your MS PE or Dean's letter
please rise when I call your row when
your row will be called and proceed to
the ramp to my left when your name is
called come up to receive your diploma
from dr. Goldman and then walk down the
ramp on my right and return to your seat
cata unis Adame
Mohsen s Ahmed
Sunil P I mean Eric J aureus
James J ATRA
Lamont Jay Barlow
Alison Barnes Callahan
Priya Batra Jason abt SHINee SIA and
beecher she lovey Bilardo Daniel M Burke
Maur biscotti the third
James board Lee v Alexandra J Borst
Michael K Mountain
Christopher a B Boyle Laura and Brenner
Marcelle Bruce Raymer
Adam M buck
Daniel W Berk
Kelly L Burke Louisa s cannon
Matthew B can't lend Ryan T cassoulet
Peter and Chalmers Isaac Chen
making Chan
allene why Chang
Maggie Jay Chou
David why Chum
Babak RC say David t-coil
Elizabeth a Dale Meghan eat daily
Ephraim why us Dickinson
Anthony Oh sting
Elizabeth J diver
Catherine II Dodds Nicholas M Donnan
Peter s downy Peter F Duggan
mark deed irska
Barbara L Edwards 8 on e HS Gary s
escola
Kelly and fall Frieden Erica dif'rent
Gladys Felix
Serie C feuless Michael L finger head
Laura Eve Fisher
Jean M France own Ronald W Galbraith
Mina as George
Alexandra M greenio Elliot I Gradstein
Jennifer Ehle Halleck
Magne hamsa Benjamin G Hassid Jonathan a
Mattoon Brandon s Hayes Melanie and hood
Jason a hub
Kathy K Kwang Emily II her stack Jeremy
see who on Lindsay M Ennis Ryan
MJ IV Wang Zhi
John M Casimir
Emily's seek honor
Jennifer Ehle Caston Jacob L Kaufman
James T Kearns David T Kent
Nora Khateeb
Abraham D Kim
rosemary ku Alexandra Lajoie lacy NP
Lyndell frien a Landsman crystal Jay
Larson
Jenna and Lee and Julie
Leslie Kaylee Adam w ly sure s teen age
Lenya on the fourth Lorraine Lopez
Shawn X Lua
Michael ARMA Christi J mashita Christina
L mallets Hanny our Malone
Robert a McGovern the third Alexander s
McLawhorn Kathleen a McManus Daniel C
Medina Zoe a Miller
Linnea M Mills Kelly L Milton Daniel K
moon Aaron C Murphy
Martha our Niaga Emily l new caramel tea
Norris
Christopher a O'Neal
Christopher Ortiz Kristin a pastor Ken
Jill Patel Ravi Pathak
Hector our Perez Hilton a finishing mark
Philip see Pimentel Sara capelet Jason
oppressor elvenar Rajkumar
Courtney ear acre Christopher Ramos
yelling erect men Shawn and Reynolds
Timothy our rice
Sarah Richards Kim
the Rhone Wrangler Marie Roku ski
his Subaru
Jhansi Ryan
Rene see Sanger Tristan TJ sends Vincent
M scintilla Nina a sexina Vikram V
Saxena
Trevor P Scott
Catherine M Seeger
Jose M Silva Catherine Simon
Caitlyn are sniffling Massa a sore up
Jessica Jason Moen son Robert a surah
Bella
Matthew Spotnitz
Megan be spires Michael T Stark Daniel H
Stephens Mary L Stevenson
melissa some pre-teach a diaper Rumple
Danielle F treif ug inside
Benjamin seat wheel Emily a veil
Matthew be wallenstein Lily see Wang
Matthew Jay Weinstock
so Phoebe Wells Gregory D Weston
Salomon L Waldo Gillian s wolf
Zachary Chi right Kyle L whoo
Shan Mei H were Caroline a Yao
Jason whyyyy
and Vijay you're a Bundy
graduates please rise for the
Hippocratic oath found in your program
in our profession it is a custom
established more than two thousand years
ago that no one may be admitted to its
honors who has not first expressly
undertaken its obligations
now therefore I call upon you to take as
we have taken before you the oath which
bears the name of Hippocrates the
language in which our predecessors first
pronounced it is no longer spoken the
very gods whom they call to witness have
been discarded but still we can find no
nobler words than the most ancient in
which to hand down the traditions of our
calling please join with me I do
solemnly swear by whatsoever each of us
holds most sacred that I will be loyal
to the profession of medicine and just
and generous to its members that I will
lead my life and practice my art and
uprightness and honor that into
whatsoever house I shall enter it shall
be for the good of the sick to the
utmost of my power am i holding myself
far aloof from wrong from corruption
from the tempting of others to vice that
I will exercise my art solely for the
Cure of my patients and will give no
drug perform no operation for a criminal
purpose even if solicited far less
suggested that whatsoever I shall see or
hear of the lives of my patients which
is not fitting to be spoken I will keep
enviably secret these things do I swear
let each of us bow the head and sign of
acquiescence and now if I will be true
to this my oath may good repute ever be
mine the opposite if I shall prove
myself for sworn please remain standing
for the benediction
we give thanks for each of you care for
us care for us all Godspeed
this is both a graduation and as we
always call it a commencement it's a
graduation because today's doctors
whether they be PhD or MD have completed
extraordinarily vigorous set of
requirements you have proven in the
classroom in the laboratory and the
clinics and in the wards how special you
are now this phase is over you can think
about commencement this begins your
careers as scientists as physicians as
healers we hope we've trained you well
we know from all the people who've
joined you here today in many ways
you're well trained even before you
arrived here we wish you more than just
not screwing it up well that's a good
start we wish you the best in your
careers as you go to cure disease to
make humanity better there's no more
noble calling no more noble profession
we know that as have many generations
before you you're up to the task you'll
all make the world better thank you
everyone
you